belgium it's a country which often has
to justify its own existence sandwiched
between france germany and the
netherlands its population is divided
amongst those who speak well french
german and dutch since about six seconds
after its foundation other nations have
often spoke of dividing belgium up so
given how often its existence has both
been questioned and threatened there's
an obvious question to answer why does
belgium exist the first thing to answer
is how belgium came into existence in
the first place after the napoleonic
wars europe was a drastically changed
continent and one of the major changes
that occurred was that the austrian
netherlands was incorporated into the
brand new united kingdom of the
netherlands king william the first of
the netherlands was a protestant to add
little interest in preserving the rights
of the south's catholic residents he
used much of the south's industrialized
economy to fund the north and he was
also a bit of a despot this was
obviously a problem and in 1830 when
riots broke out talk soon turned to
secession william tried to crush the
revolt but many troops in the south
quickly defected william needed help and
so he asked the great powers for
assistance and the great powers did help
but they helped the south and recognize
the new country's independence and their
new country was called belgium
recognition of independence was done on
one condition it had to be a monarchy
because none of that republicanism stuff
absolutely not the belgians would
finally have a king that would represent
them a local a catholic and a man who
wouldn't try to expand the power of the
monarchy and become a despot instead
they got leopold the first a
german-speaking protestant who quickly
expanded the power of the monarchy but
you know zero out of three isn't bad
even with leopold belgium had come out
ahead given that at the london
conference france had proposed that
belgium be divided between its neighbors
this was the tally rand plan and was
rejected by the british because france
can't have nice things had been british
foreign policy for over 400 years at
this point and that wasn't going to
change any time soon also to britain
belgium was seen as an important buffer
state that would limit the scale of any
future franco-prussian war in theory
william the first didn't accept bulge in
independence and so invaded in 1831 but
the french came to the belgian's aid and
sent the dutch packing in 1839 william
accepted belgian independence and the
netherlands would never again try to
reclaim the south which now included
this land from luxembourg and it was
also in this year that britain
guaranteed belgian neutrality
immediately after belgium's formation
tensions arose between the
dutch-speaking population in the north
the flemish and the french-speaking
southerners the walloons whose language
was the official language of the state
the initial hope was to get northerners
over time to speak french but fun fact
no tensions between the two groups would
rise but the threat to dissolve belgium
never went anywhere since both peoples
largely saw unity within belgium as
better than the alternatives so what
about any future threats finding out why
belgium exists in the first place isn't
the same as asking why it still exists
and the fledgling nation wasn't without
its concerns french and german leaders
coveted parts of belgium in the late
19th and early 20th centuries but the
british guarantee in a fear of upsetting
the balance of power stopped any action
it wasn't until world war one that the
second tangible threat to belgium's
existence occurred when german troops
crossed into the country in order to get
to france germany occupied most of the
country and after the war the plan was
for these areas to be annexed into
germany and these areas would become a
rump state under a new monarchy towards
the end of the war germany made a
concession on these demands and would
respect belgian independence so long as
it was split into two nations the
northern flemish one being aligned with
germany who would gain antwerp this
never happened because obviously in
germany eventually lost the war belgium
then got to sit at the winner's table
and was even given this territory from
germany although at first belgium had
made much larger demands because it
wanted to annex luxembourg and to take
territory from the neutral dutch since
apparently belgium holds a grudge the
last threat to belgian existence came
during world war ii when it was
conquered it was originally administered
as a single unit along with a chunk of
northern france but hitler had very
little in the way of concrete plans the
belgian collaborators had hoped for
belgium to be split like this with
flanders being merged with the
netherlands yet germany was unwilling
and unable to do this since it was busy
losing the war in late 1944 germany then
formally annexed belgium a plan which
had one snag it had already been
liberated and so that's not how that
works no other nation would threaten
belgian existence thereafter and all
attempts to split the state would from
then on be internal in nature belgium's
existence is actually quite remarkable
given that it spent one of the most
dangerous periods in european history
sandwiched between two nations that
really liked annexing things in the end
the belgian people would find union
together despite their differences much
more compelling than any of the
alternatives and that is why belgium
exists i hope you enjoyed this episode
and a special thanks to my patreon
supporters james bissonette john lucid
danny maloney a man of culture marvin
castell john bisquez mo rob waterhouse
james castaneda aaron the white jordan
longley gustav swan marcus asner rasheed
ali fielder oink oink izzy spinning
three plates david silverman maggie
paxkowski spencer lightfoot winston k
wood robert wetzel anthony beckett lexi
schwinn skye chappelle and kelly
moneymaker
i mean it wasn't a bad plan exactly